and haps the Senate these days has the
sexism got better I know you write a lot
about that in the book and some of its
kind of funny well it was terrible when
I was young now it's not that it really
IRA belen the sense that they would
actually make comments oh yeah in my
book I talk about the Speaker of the
House when I was a freshman legislator
in Jefferson City I asked him how I
could get my bill out of committee I was
up in the diocese and the House of
Representatives and he looked at me and
he said well did you bring your kneepads
and so that that that's in the book so
what did you say back I kind of laughed
and I talked about maybe I didn't handle
it right because I was young and this
was in 1983 right I did it is amazing
what men were able to get away with you
know maybe the the pendulum has swung so
far now that you know you can't even say
to a woman in the office you look nice
without worrying oh no we just had
another intern sex scandal in the
Missouri legislature six months ago as
my book was at print you know so we
haven't gotten there yet I will say I've
never been disrespected or marginalized
in the United States Senate by my
colleagues I think they realized that
women that get to the United States
Senate don't mess with them I mean we're
pretty tough cookie
you